Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in the book of prayer
from Aliz in the timings of salah
and currently we're discing
discussing the times in which it is
prohibited to pray and the instances in
which a person may pray and the
instances that do not apply to that
prohibition. After these chapters,
we will be following this up with the
book of then because the times of prayer
of course weren't a then. And so we will
be discussing the adan, how it's made,
the different types of adan, the
different types of
what's interesting is
we were to ask a question. If we were to
say, what is the greatest enemy to
knowledge? What is it?
Ignorance.
Ignorance isn't really that much of a
problem if you think about it, right?
Ignorance is not knowing something. How
do we fix it? By knowing it. Ignorance
is easily remedied.
What's the greatest enemy to knowledge?
Huh?
[Arabic recitation]
not not the one I'm looking for. There's
still a greater he mentioned
forgetfulness that there's still a
greater enemy to knowledge.
The greatest enemy to knowledge
is compounded ignorance.
See ignorance is two types.
You have as
tell tell us
is simple or
is
profound ignorance which means a
person is just completely ignorant a
blank slate. Now you can write on that
slate anything you want as long as the
person is neither arrogant nor too
ashamed to learn too proud.
But then there is something called
compounded ignorance.
That's the greatest enemy to knowledge.
What is alah
is a person being ignorant of something
and ignorant of their own ignorance.
This is the problem. In other words,
they don't know something correctly, but
they are positive that they already know
it. How do you fix that?
How do you fix
and try to teach a person who's already
convinced that they already know? That
is always the greatest enemy to
knowledge is the illusion of
knowledge.
And there is no shame at all in us
sitting together and learning things
that we've been doing all our lives. We
are trying to prepare ourselves to go
and meet Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. If
you ever go to the military or if you
ever go to any serious endeavor, you'll
find that they check things and check
them twice and three times and 10 times
and they have protocols in case of
protocols in case of protocols. No one
is too proud to check their parachute
before they jump out of a plane. No one
is too proud to have someone else check
their parachute before they jump out of
a plane.
And so a person must always fight this
within himself. Always fight this within
himself. No matter how long a person
studies, no matter how intelligent they
are, they will always miss something.
They will always misunderstand. Allah is
the only one who is described as
My lord neither becomes confused
nor does he ever forget. That's Allah
only.
No one else has that description.
Listen to this narration. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam
was listening to one of the companions
recite
and the companion didn't know that he
was listening. And upon conclusion, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam commented
and said,
he said, "May Allah have mercy on
that companion. He reminded me of a
verse
such and such." This is the messenger of
Allah reminded you of a verse. Yes,
that is the description of Allah. He's
neither confused nor is he nor does he
forget. We as human beings, Allah tells
us,
remind for indeed the reminder is always
of consequence for the believer. For the
believer.
And so we must never ever allow
ourselves to be too proud. The one of
the greatest students and it's said that
he is the greatest student of Abdullahb
Abbas.
His name
is
Iban Abbi
and he was a great muhadith
and he lived to be very very old
over the age of 80.
He's a major muhadith. His narrations
are found in all of the six books of
hadith. He's the greatest companion
of Iban Abbass. And not only that, but
when he would enter Mecca, which is
where he resided, fetwa was prohibited
by law
to be given by anyone other than him as
long as he is in Mecca.
Imagine the prestige.
And if I described him to you, he was a
linky black man with one of his eyes
injured.
very very very curly hair and he was
an ouch. He walked with a with a limp.
Right? This is Islam.
And so he said
a man would narrate to me a narration
and I heard and memorized that narration
before he was born.
But I would listen to it as if it's the
first time I ever heard it.
Out of respect for who? The prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Who
am I to cut him off? Say I already know
that. Who do you think you're talking
to? I knew that narration before you
were born. That person will never learn.
Right? And so it's very important for us
to always review knowledge. Always
review knowledge. Always review
knowledge.
Said,
"A man will never reach the heights of
knowledge and excellence until he takes
knowledge from those who are above him
in stature, those who are his peers and
those who are his students.
In order to reach the positions of
excellence in knowledge, you must be
willing to take from anywhere that
knowledge comes. And as the companions
would say
that wisdom and knowledge is the lost
property of every believer. Wherever he
finds it, he takes it from there. He has
more of a right to it.
and
Abdul,
our great
leaderbiz.
He mentioned that just as
the
lowest parts of the earth
are the places where that hold the most
water,
right? The physical earth. Where do you
go to find water? Do you go to the top
of a mountain looking for water? No. You
go to the lowest point that you can
find. That's where you'll find water.
And the lower the part is, the more
water it holds. He said, "Likewise, the
most humble are those who hold the most
knowledge."
The most humble are those who hold the
most knowledge.
And one of the wisdoms of the earlier
generations of Islam, they said,
[Silence]
They say they would say if you find
yourself in the presence of knowledge
and the people of knowledge
always make your response as much as
possible I don't know because If you go
to the people of knowledge and you say,
"I don't know." with your tongue, with
your behavior, with your attitude, they
will teach you until you know.
And beware of I know.
Because if you go and find yourself in
the company of the people of knowledge
and you say, "I know," they will ask you
until you do not know.
Right? And so this is how knowledge is
sought. little bit at every single day.
Little bit, little bit, little bit. Over
time, you find that you've accumulated a
lot and you take it in naturally.
You know, we always fantasize as human
beings in the sci-fi world today. We
fantasize about
being able to download knowledge
into your mind, you know, if you
could hook your mind up to a computer
and download all of the knowledge,
that's unnatural. Humans aren't supposed
to learn that. That would actually
be a catastrophe.
That's not power. That is ignorance.
Knowledge is to be won over by a kind of
seeking and hunting and desire. And
there has to be a level of anticipation
that preludes knowledge in order for you
to properly digest it. There would be no
difference between that and trying to
download food into your stomach. It
doesn't work that way. You cannot do
that. You have to digest it.
And people digest at different speeds.
Some people can eat a steak and be ready
2 hours later to eat eat again. And some
people eat a steak and they're they're
out for the count, right? They need they
need 10 hours to digest it. And people
are different. So it is very critical
for us to never be of the people of I
know. I already know. That's the most
dangerous place to find yourself
because when you meet Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, you're going to be asked if you
know it or not.
Knowledge is very much money.
Everyone wants to show off with it.
Everyone wants to have it. It's a
vanity.
But truly having knowledge is what
separates the men from the lions.
You opened your book. You thought we
were going to read something, right?
[Arabic recitation]
something.
Yeah. How you doing? I'm all right.
[Arabic recitation]